but space is hard may I suggest that
that become the new space force motto
this cast is out of this world how did
you both get involved in this series and
how did they pitch it to you um it
started for me I just I'd done this show
we were Americanizing this show called
the wrong mans and we did a pilot for
Showtime and it just ended and the day
after we found out I wasn't getting
picked up was the day like eighty one
audition for space force which for me as
I've told John is if it was just Greg
Daniels I would be in if it was just
John I would be in if it was just Steve
I would be in and the idea that it was
all three of them it was a show that I
knew I would be watching every second of
and I'd be bummed out if I couldn't be a
part of it so I really want to be part
of it that's kind of how it started I
auditioned talked to Greg during the
audition that we want to make it
separate from John Ralphie oh and it
looked I looked out that I was able to
get the role
what about you John Oh for me more or
less the same um I was working in London
doing a play and I got send the script I
thinking about August maybe something
like that Greg sent me a long note via
email I read the first two scripts and I
thought I mean especially this second
episode with the chimpanzee I just I was
just crying it's so well written John I
remember reading an episode it's so Greg
Daniels Rory and it's oh it's so alright
it is so funny and so pathetic
so you'd see how absolutely clueless and
overmatched everyone is and yet the the
great sort of efforts all the all the
hope they ply into this doomed mission
which just couldn't have ended
more badly like ads as Blanche DuBois
said in a streetcar named desire things
have a way of turning out so bad that
just couldn't have turned out worse but
that's what's so funny about it that's
why I I just thought this is just to
watch this it wouldn't even matter if I
were in it just to watch it going on
it's so it's so pitiful that it's just
though reading it and watching it those
days we were shooting that I mean I just
was sick from laughing just how
desperate it was how how ugly and funny
it really is hilarious I mean even the
chimpanzee named Marcus had me dinosaur
fect but yeah it's so right because it
was so perfectly cast both of your
characters dr. Adrien Mallory as timoni
spend a lot of time with Steve so can
you share with us maybe some
behind-the-scenes moments that the three
of you had the two of you had it stood
out to you Ben really makes me laugh
alone and I always love scenes where I
wasn't really doing anything and I could
watch what Ben and normally done
Lakewood because somehow in every scene
they somehow ended up next to each other
you know that behind your back or behind
Steve's back or whatever somewhere off
off the cameras side there's a whole
world happening I would start doing
things when when let's say Steve was on
camera and John was a little bit to his
right and then we're in the background I
would do things just to try to get john
malkovich the actor to laugh and we
would be and Don and I would be playing
because we knew we
John is such a good actor he's so aware
of the space that Don and I will be
doing stupid little bits with each other
and John will come over laughing and be
like were you guys just playing a game
while he was talking about the earth to
being destroyed and then the second I
knew that John is aware of what we're
doing behind him it becomes like a
beautiful game one of the things that I
remember the most out of playing with
Steve was we did one scene where I'm
supposed to get yelled at and so what
happens is I mess up somehow and the
next scene that was written was him
taking me to a room and we have a
discussion about it and one of the takes
Steve goes
come here come with me and instead
improvises the scene to remember this
John where he takes me outside and he
curses me off so loudly and so like in
character like his the words barely made
sense that we erased the whole other
scene and we just kept this little part
of him being like I mean I was coming
back in and that stuff is great but I
will say it is dory
hey don't you say Mike it's fine or he
God oh yeah yeah Don goes have that guy
go it's good we're good we worked it out
but I don't know if they kept it in but
it was I will say that yeah yeah I think
they did Oh perfect it's been so fun
playing with John - because - because Oh
John's character all this comedy comes
from John's character so when you
combine our two characters you could
just leave us in a room together just
talking and comedy kind of happens which
is it makes me so happy Meza Testament
to Greg crating you know that is the
that's what I felt
reading it is just all the characters
were so funny
to me and just so lifelike in the wrong
way sure that doesn't really matter
because the wrong way in the end makes
it like us like people and you know
generally we don't get it that's what's
hilarious yeah it's it's so relatable
and we're laughing because we're just
seeing ourselves and the fact that space
warts is
actually a thing and I'm sure there are
gonna be so many similarities it's crazy
how the thing is coming out our show
will be coming out as things are
happening in parallel in real time which
has been so like they had announced that
this is what our emblem looks like so
Greg is like well this is what our
Emelyn looks like we had written it back
when they announced me or rather week
Greg and Steve and all of them were
writing it back then so it's been so
surreal to see these things happen in
real time it's been used been sent last
week because we have a several of us
have a sort of text group and he sent
which I was just starting to send to
everybody but he refused to send and
this was the real space force ad which
was oh yeah if you weren't meant to live
on this planet or some version there it
bit and I would go well that's true for
all of us we are you talking to me yeah
well and that's the real ad and when you
look at this group and these characters
you go hey he can't be the social media
person for spaceforce he can't be the
head of space force he can't be the
scientists of space force but they are
well I'm gonna use the hashtag that Ben
is use to close this out hashtag that's
all I needed
thanks for talking to me this is a dream
come true I Congrats on Middleditch in
schwarz 100% a it's still there I just
checked oh I can't wait
thank you so good my main concern is our
head scientists this is the moon flat
deathlike the surface is actually a
complex topography
thank you Bill the Science Guy my
favorite scenes in the show are when the
both of you are together and
you both are comedians so it's curious
did you guys get to improvise any lions
or scenes in the show yeah and I think
some of the storyline came from our
pitching too which is so great of the
writing staff being open you know the
black women Asian men relationship stuff
I just love that they're so sweet
there's something so sweet about us too
because it's so unlikely I think in the
real world and I absolutely love that
and all the dancing and stuff we learn
all that we just like the dance
instructor came up with it like we just
and we just did it the same day so those
days were really really fun yeah I love
that stuff too and I love yeah the
writers were so they had us in to talk
with them a couple of different times to
just be like well what would you really
you know how would you explore a
friendship like this or a relationship
like this um Greg - so open I mean there
was a point where they had written some
scenes for us that like just didn't
fully feel like where we were taking the
the relationship or something and so I
said like oh I'm not sure maybe could we
improvise around this and Greg was like
yeah [ __ ] whatever you want so it
really did feel like a true
collaboration which I know everyone says
that but I I wouldn't say I wouldn't lie
yeah it's true because you can feel it
while watching it I feel like it there's
so much of you guys in these characters
and you both are just be wham couple
goals in my is there anything that ended
up on the cutting room floor that you
and Jimmy and provides together or Jimmy
you know what luckily I think our scenes
were pretty much all there right tani
yeah I was really surprised and
flattered at that because we did play
around a lot but really I think because
we met with the writers and played
around with them they wrote down a lot
of what we said and they you know made
it better of course but uh yeah they
kind of left our stuff intact and I was
so happy with us I did I texted Toni
about this I did improvise one line that
I semi redirect at the end of the car
the beginning the first car scene at the
end of it when I was talking about my
Korean friends and stuff and I said yeah
and yeah grandma Kim was a [ __ ] you
know about about my buddy but then that
was really based on a story that was a
real
Mr Kim and she was actually like really
sweet so now I'm sure my buddy's gonna
come after me now and beat me up after
he saw that yeah now that's recorded
forever you calling his grandma a [ __ ]
wait ma Kim is very nice let me go on
record to say that grandma Kim was not a
[ __ ] you guys heard it here first I
can't wait to hear grandma kids reaction
to this Jimmy you specifically I know
you're always spilling the tea your
character in the show spends a lot of
time with dr. Adrienne Mallory John
Malkovich ever what was it like really
working with John Malkovich man I think
the first day for me Anton and probably
everyone that has ever work with John
Malcolm just like I can't believe it is
a legend you know I'm kind of nervous I
make sure I'm prepared but then he just
so disarming man he's just a chill guy
and he's a great storyteller in between
scenes in between takes so we quickly
became very close friends I think I had
a little breakthrough well not that you
know I think he was very warm from the
beginning but in Episode four I say this
fart joke line and I just remember John
like kind of broke and out laughing and
one of the takes and I was like oh my
god I made John Malkovich laugh and I
think from then on I mean we just became
like pretty close friends and I call him
every now and then we have little zoom
happy hours and stuff so it's incredible
man and now I don't even see him as John
Malkovich she's just like a buddy you
know you're having zoom happy hours and
John Malkovich it's a minimal pass the
whole cast at the hour it's really good
this whole cast is the coolest thing
Jimmy you bring up your parents a lot
here stand up and by the way good deal
is just so hilarious
it was my parents reaction to like you
working with Steve Carell and John
Malkovich or everyone on this show well
so I think at the beginning of my acting
career especially my dad he's quite
vocal he's like I hope this is just a
face go get a real job and then when he
saw some success he made a complete 180
and was like ABS so easy you can do it I
can probably do it and I was like sure
you know what why don't you start trying
to go to some auditions and you see how
hard it is you know and then he started
actually kind of killing it so I was
kind of happy for them and then I don't
know if you noticed this but in episode
9 there's this older Chinese scientist
on the Skype screen that's
opposite John Malkovich that's my dad
does anyone know that I think people are
hopefully starting to and I mean come on
yeah and he was the most fun and he
killed that scene and he was very funny
so very happy for him that is hot taani
what about you what was it like working
with Steve because your character has a
lot of nice moments with mark general
mark our naired yeah a lot of nice
moments with him on screen and off I
mean some some of those days like Steve
and I maybe were the only actors on set
you know because they were kind of like
a long set ups or you know just us in
the helicopter and he's just the nicest
most regular guy I was talking to him
about my house that I had just bought
and he was talking to me about his
daughter going to college like just the
most normal everyday conversations and
then like so sweet in the like in the
actual filming like you know because
he's the boss - he's a producer but like
I feel like in the first few episodes I
didn't get any acting notes or notes at
all other than just like move your chin
over here for this camera and so it's
kind of like looking around being like
am i terrible and they're going to
replace me or am i a genius what's
happening here but like I think I asked
him once I was like is what I'm doing
okay like Dini me do something different
and he was just like do you do whatever
you want it was just such a like warm
like he just you know trusted me and
that gave me a lot of confidence well
I'm gonna go with genius on that one
tani thank you guys so much for you
talking with me this is like a dream
come true Jimmy thank you for your pasta
recipes on Instagram I think I hope you
guys have a fabulous day you're staying
safe and thanks thank you I'm so proud
of you
my god I have feel we're gonna call 14
the shared space for spirit
congratulations on the show I mean this
shows very much a satire but what I love
about both of your characters is we get
to see some very real and tender moments
between the both of you and Steve Carell
is character mark general mark our
naired Lisa you specifically I know you
guys worked together before on web
therapy but what was it like working
together with him now as his wife yeah
it was heaven because he's so great he's
I mean such a good actor number one he's
so funny number two but then as a person
he is so professional and warm and
welcoming and just you know and Greg
Daniels - they were all just so nice and
having me participate in this it was
really great I have to say I really felt
welcome I loved watching you guys on web
therapy and I remember watching an
interview that you did where you talked
about where he came up to you and he
almost like kissed you but now when
you're his wife I was like she finally
got to kiss Steve Grissom yeah and it
had to be such a goofy one - I loved it
I loved it I don't want to give away too
much about your character your character
so incredible - but it has some
restrictions in this show Lisa so did
you find performing the character
restrictive at all well I mean I just
ran different scenarios in my head and
thought now if that's what's happening
does this work yes yeah so I just you
know made sure whatever I was doing it
would didn't take that much work - you
know I mean you know she's a dude in
Washington DC military wife so yeah
were there any behind-the-scenes moments
that maybe we don't get to see on camera
between you and Steve that stood out to
you or that'll stay with you forever
stay with me forever I mean you know the
whole experience I mean it was mostly
just that general feeling he did say you
know you should go off on this and and
he gave me like you know different
improv things to like throw out that I
can't say but that was really
that was really fun that was funny he
was right and funny
you both are hilarious together and you
to Diana I mean I know you're a huge fan
of the office well what is it like
having Octavia Spencer as your MA and
Steve Carell is your dog oh wow
nice very good honestly I don't know
I've definitely been pretty lucky and my
on-screen parents and you know seen
partners
Steve Carell is the is just creme de la
creme he's so wonderful and easy to work
with he's definitely made me a better
actor same with Lisa my scenes at Lisa
you know and a lot of our scene repeated
with Dana Reed and we said Dan as the
director and just both of them really
just pushed me to just be a better actor
and tried different things and different
scenarios and I've been really lucky and
I'm just I hope I get to go back and
keep doing it with them yeah I
definitely want to see more of this show
was there anything that you learned you
know from anyone on this because this
cast
I mean it's star-studded s-- is there
anything you learn from you know an
actor specifically that you're gonna
take with you moving forward I
definitely Steve is a very present
person and his scene where like he's
just she's so there with you just like
the way he makes eye contact honestly
and scenes was enough to teach me a big
lesson of like getting into character
and preparing for a scene and connecting
to the person you're in the scene with
so I definitely have taken that with me
and will continue to do so
we also Dianna we also heard about this
incident that you had before your
audition that sort of yeah so I was in
my apartment cleaning because I had
bedbugs in New York and I was on a
ladder kind of does something off and
the fan was on behind me whatever I hit
my head blood concussion er it was great
times and then the next day I had to go
to Los Angeles
to have a week of auditions one of which
was space force and I'm really really
glad that I kept getting called back
well I'm glad you ladies are so great in
this show I can't wait for the world to
see it and thank you so much for taking
the time to talk to us
congratula Nisqually Annika and you're
not the most flexible person keep up
Greg congratulations on upload on space
forest quarantine has been lit thanks to
you as so many people are so excited
about space forest I actually pulled a
quote from a comment someone wrote on
social media I wanted to read to you
someone said oh my god Michael Scott
Phoebe Buffay
jean-ralphio Frank Dunphy and Sue
Sylvester this must be good and rest in
peace Fred Willard but we wanted to know
how did you get everyone involved him
what was the pitch you know it started
with Steve and I having lunch and saying
we really should do another TV comedy
together and the office was you know my
favorite professional experience and
it's being able to do seven years with
him on that show was just you know
fantastic so I was into it no matter
really what the idea was and then he
took a meeting at Netflix and they
proposed to him to do something about
space force so he called me and said
what about space force I was like yeah
I'm in this is great we you know we
found it really funny to picture the
real-life general who has been given the
mission of boots on the moon by 2024
which is you know a big big task and
will require a lot of science knowledge
and creativity and flexibility and you
know we just sort of pictured this guy
who hadn't really used all those all
those you know traits in climbing up the
ladder at the Air Force and it seemed
very funny and then you know Netflix
made an announcement right away that we
were going to do that show which was a
little nerve-wracking but what it led to
was John Malkovich's agent calling and
saying hey Malkovich saw the
announcement he'd love to be a part of
it so that was you know fantastic and
then we we were able to write his carrot
from the beginning as the the head
science advisor who's kind of plays off
Steve the most you know and then you
think to yourself okay well a modern
general has to tweet and they have to
interact with the media so we wrote this
part for Ben Schwartz to be his media
advisor and then you know what's it like
for him at home dealing with all this
and we tried to put even more pressure
on him with his family with Lisa Kudrow
and Diana Silver's and what's going on
with them which I'm not gonna spoil but
it's crazy so it was kind of like played
out like that and then well you know
it's just it's a comedy murderers row
really it's like and and and the
highlight really was Fred Willard and
you know his appearance of the only
appeared a few times in the series but
they were really beautiful moments and
you know it was so sad that he passed
away by at least I feel like the last
you know stuff that he did was just as
brilliant as his long career I'm just
gonna say it was like some of his best
stuff really cool that he's in this show
like you mentioned obviously working
with Steve I didn't know that the office
is you know one of your favorites that
you've ever worked on so that's called a
know um people people know that you and
Steve have worked together and I feel
like some people are gonna go into this
expecting a mockumentary style format
like the office so can you explain what
the ethos of space forces to us sure I
mean I think that people are you know at
least when it was announced I think
people were expecting that it was a
mockumentary set on a spaceship you know
and it's really nothing like that and I
think if you looked at the trailer or
just see the beginning of the show it'll
be clear right away that we're going for
something different
the lead character mark naired is really
nothing like Michael Scott he's like
this super good leader and very high
integrity military guy who you know if
he has any problem it's being a little
too inflexible whereas you know Michael
obviously blue every which way no matter
was happening too and the show is very
cinematic and the scope of the idea of
starting a new space force is just very
grand and you know we got a wonderful
cinematography we have beautiful music
Carter Burwell did the score with a full
orchestra
Simon Chapman cinematographer we had
great directors Paul King the director
Paddington you know does the first few
episodes degrease from mud bound is you
know does the hump up stuff in the
middle and just everybody was you know
very high-end and so it's good it's got
a lot of beautiful sort of scope you
know it's like a very I guess it's sort
of like a funny Apollo 13 movie in look
perfect description you mentioned how
you know mock general mark our narrative
isn't like Michael sky and I don't want
to give anything away but he does have
some Michael Scott ESCA moments like for
example in the trailer he's singing
Kokomo by the Beach Boys it's no good by
Toby
but it's amazing nonetheless was that
done on purpose or in mind well you know
we we certainly are trying to have this
be a unique character I think anytime
people see Steve being funny and hear
his voice you know there may be some
memories of Michael Scott involved which
is also good I think that was a great
character also but so you know once
people get into the story I think that
they'll accept this new character and
see that he's being funny in different
ways than Michael was behind reverse and
um yeah my dad was in four branches of
the military so I really I know that
he's gonna love this and I saw so much
of him in it so I think you guys just
really know Steve and I both have
relatives to the military Steve's dad
was in World War two and so it was very
important to us to be very respectful
and being making a show that people the
military would embrace and find funny
you know and feel like they're laughing
with them and everybody understands them
yeah and I felt that when I was watching
I was like my dad's gonna love this so
thank you for doing that and cool it's
really been cool dragon
fan just seeing you bring your comedy to
streaming and just creating these worlds
and upload is very you know cinematic as
well so congratulations on all your
success thanks for making us laugh
during this time let's thank you thank
you so much and take care fifty years
ago our country put a man on the moon
guess what kids
we're going back
[Music]